today's video is brought to you by monk pack
tasty low sugar keto friendly snack bars
more on them in just a bit
once upon a time during the closing days
of the wild west there was a group of
mean and dangerous brothers called the daltons
and together with their friends they formed a gang
that liked to rob banks and trains steal horses
and any other illicit activity that might make
them some money anyone who tried to interfere
with their felonious enterprises at a good
chance of getting pumped full of lead and ditched
by the side of the road but then october 5th 1892
gang leader bob dalton decided that five of
them would enter the city of coffeyville kansas
and robbed two banks at once in broad daylight
to show the whole world that the dalton gang was
the most feared group of outlaws in the wild west
but things didn't really go his way and a massive
shootout ensued between the dalton gang and the
people of coffeeville when the smoke settled eight
people were dead including four of the five gang
members bob dalton was dead as was his brother
grant bill powers and dick broadwell youngest
brother emmett dalton was the only survivor
despite sustaining dozens of wounds even so he
was arrested and sentenced to life in prison and
just like that the dalton gang was no more except
that a fourth brother named bill dalton was still
around on that fateful day he and another outlaw
named bill doolin may have been waiting outside
the city with fresh horses to help the gang make
their escape once they found out what had happened
to the others they resolved to form a new group
led by the two of them often they say that the
sequel is never as good as the original but that
was not the case here as the dulin dalton gang
became more successful more notorious and longer
lived than the first incarnation eventually
it gained a new name to match its fearsome
reputation it became known as the wild bunch
mason dalton was born circa 1865 in cass county
missouri to lewis dalton and adeline younger the
family relocated to kansas where mason and his
14 siblings grew up later in life he started
going by william bill dalton so we're just going
to call him that from the beginning to make it a
whole lot less confusing there are already enough
daltons going around in this video to use one with
two names his mother was related to the younger
brothers who were part of the notorious james
younger gang alongside frank jesse james the gang
predated the wild bunch by a couple of decades so
bill dalton and his brothers grew up hearing
of their uncle's daring and violent exploits
even so for a while it seemed like the dalton
boys were destined to walk on the right side
of the law the family's pride and joy was frank
dalton in 1884 he became a deputy u.s marshal for
the oklahoma territory and was considered by his
peers to be a brave and respected lawman however
he was gunned down in 1887 while attempting to
arrest a horse thief at first the other dalton
brothers thought they could pick up the mantle
left behind by big brother frank grat dalton took
over his job as deputy marshall and then hired
bob and emmett to serve as guards but it became
pretty obvious soon enough that they weren't
meant to walk the straight and narrow it started
with too much drinking and too much gambling on
the job then there were the incidents when the
brothers got a bit too trigger-happy and it
ended with plain old corruption as the boys
sought to supplement their meager salaries by
abusing their authority sometimes they would find
a person instead of arresting them other times
they would confiscate legal goods but every time
the cash and cargo seemed to mysteriously vanish
before reaching the sheriff's station ultimately
the brothers said screw it and they started
their gang as far as bill dalton was concerned
he too tried to live an honest life at first he
started out working various odd jobs with his
brothers before moving to livingston california
where he was employed by a rancher named cyrus
bliven soon after bill fell in love with the
ranch's daughter jenny bliven the two got married
in 1885 and had two children together charles
and grace it really seemed like bill dalton had
his life together he started a family he bought
his own ranch he opened a business and even got
involved in local politics the people who knew him
described him as charming good looking at the life
of the party so what exactly possessed him to turn
to a life of crime it seems that his brothers had
a negative influence on bill bob and grat and
emmett sometimes showed up bill's ranch for
a visit when they were looking to lay low from
the authorities it is possible that the brothers
committed several robberies in the late 1880s and
early 1890s and used bill's ranch as a hideout but
it is uncertain if bill ever joined them in any
of their ventures he finally showed up on the
sheriff's radar in 1891 when somebody committed
a train robbery in the town of alilah california
which involved the murder of a locomotive fireman
named george radcliffe bob and emmitt dalton were
wanted for the crime he managed to flee
to california but bill and gret dalton
were arrested for helping them escape even though
all charges against bill were eventually dropped
his reputation was tarnished forever and he was
considered to be just another no good dalton boy
at this point there was no use in pretending
anymore so bill accepted his new role in life as
an outlaw although we're not really sure to what
extent he participated in the illicit activities
of the dalton gang who knows after the coffeeville
massacre with his brothers dead or in jail
bill may have been tempted to return to
ranching if it wasn't for another man
we're on with the second namesake of the doolin
dalton gang william doolan born circa 1858 on a
homestead northeast of clarksville arkansas
his parents were michael doolin and artemia
bella a pair of law-abiding sharecroppers bill
worked on the family farm until 1881 at which
point the 23 year old left the homestead to find
his own way in life like bill dalton he didn't
seem to be particularly inclined toward a
life of crime which makes it all the more
curious that they ended up leading one of
the most notorious gangs of the wild west
in the oklahoma territory doolin found work as a
cowboy on the ranch of a texan named oscar halsell
who liked bill enough to take him under his wing
and teach him to read and write this was doolan's
life for the next 10 years drifting from one ranch
to another filling whatever position was needed
we know that during this time he met some of
the men who would later form part of his gang
but we're not sure exactly what prompted
bill to turn to robbery by 1891 however
he was a member of the dalton gang and became an
outlaw following a shootout in coffeeville kansas
strangely enough this isn't the aforementioned
bloody gunfight that got the two dalton brothers
killed and ended the gang this happened a year
earlier when doolin and a few cohorts wanted to
celebrate the 4th of july with a keg of beer
but kansas was a dry state at the time and
the local lorman didn't take kindly to
drunkards around there except that doolin
and his friends didn't take kindly to local
lawmen trying to confiscate their hooch so
both sides started shooting at each other
resulting in two injuries and a life on the run
for bill doolin tulin had a somewhat contentious
relationship with the dalton brothers particularly
bob dalton who often acted as the leader of the
group some sources claim that doolin briefly
left the gang alongside two other members named
charlie pierce and george bittercreek newcomb who
are worth mentioning as they would later be
a part of the wild bunch all three of them
were angry with the daltons because they felt bob
wasn't quite equitable when it came to divvying up
the loot it seems this was one of those situations
where everyone was equal but some were more equal
than the others and some of the core members
of the dalton gang received bigger shares than
the rest ultimately this worked out in doolin's
favor after all if he were one of bob dalton's
trusty sidekicks then he probably would have been
present in coffee pill on the day of the gunfight
and ended up in a cheap box right next to bob and
the others but as things stood after october 5th
1892 bill doolin was now an independent gunman
ready to strike out on his own all right we'll
get back to our video in just a second but first
here's a word from today's fantastic sponsor
monk pack bunk pack offers low sugar keto friendly
bars which are plant-based gluten-free and non-gmo
but the perfect snack for anyone who's trying to
eat better or cut back on sugar and carbs without
sacrificing taste monk back keto granola bars
and nuts and seed bars this is nuts and seeds
this is one of their granola bars they contain
one gram of sugar or less two to three grams
of net carbs and each bar contains 150 calories
or less look everyone snacks for me when i get
home from work there's probably some crisps in the
cupboard that my wife has bought and i'll be like
yeah let's stack up those because they're tasty
but since having monk pack in my cupboard i just
grab one of these and it is tasty it is delicious
this is probably my favorite the caramel sea
salt flavor i just uh like the salty and sugary
goodness i just love that and i just see one of
these instead it satiates that after work hunger
and i don't end up eating crisps which i know
are horribly bad for me mark back have a great
chewy texture and they come in delicious favors
like sea salt dark chocolate the one i mentioned
coconut cocoa chip and caramel sea salt they're
perfect for a quick breakfast a snack between
zoom calls or as a guilt-free decadent dessert
tasty stuff you guys get 20 off
finish my mouthful 20 of your first purchase of
any month pack product by visiting monkback.com
and entering my code biography so checkout and
monk pack is so confident in their products is
back with 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll exchange
the product or refund your money whichever
you prefer and now back to today's video
after the bloody shootout at coffeeville doolan
newcomb and pierce felt obligated to visit the
dalton household and pay their respects the family
matriarch who had just buried two sons and saw
another imprisoned for life while there they met
up with bill dalton and doolin floated the idea of
the four of them starting a new gang and picking
up right where things left off bill accepted and
the doolen dalton gang was born truth be told
bill dulan was the de facto leader of the group
bill dalton didn't really have the credentials to
lead gang but they probably added him in honor of
his brothers and for brand recognition since
the dalton name was already known and feared
throughout the west of course four men
might make a nice barb shop quartet but
they are not enough for a dangerous gang so the
first thing they did was to draft a few more names
to their roster we're not going to go through all
of them just know that 11 men were part of the
wild bunch at one point or another they all had
colorful names like william tulsa jack blake and
dan dynamite dick clifton and they all
ultimately met their ends in violent shootouts so
well expect a lot of gunfights in the very near
future in fact let's start right now we believe
that the first crime committed by the new and
improved gang was the robbery of the ford county
bank in spearville kansas on november 1 1892.
following their escape the authorities identified
one of the gunmen as oliver olyantis and put the
marshals on his trail they tracked down yantas
at his sister's ranch on the 29th of november
and gunned him down when the outlaw refused to
surrender gantus died of his wounds the next day
becoming the first member of the wild bunch to go
out in a hail of bullets just a month after
the gang was formed the rest of the outlaws
were more successful and spent the first half of
1893 robbing multiple trains and banks without too
much hassle but on september 1st they took part in
one event remembered in western law as one of its
fiercest gunfights and solidified their reputation
as the wild bunch it became known as the battle of
ingles named after the town of ingles oklahoma
which the criminals sometimes used as a hideout
as we mentioned by that point the gang had plenty
of successful robberies under its belt so it was
firmly on the radar of the u.s marshals who vowed
to risk life and limb in order to bring the wild
bunch to justice on september 1st 1893 a posse of
over a dozen marshals led by john nixon tracked
the outlaws to ingalls most of the gang members
had been there for weeks drinking gambling and
most importantly spending money which is why
the locals looked the other way when it came to
how they obtained their forgotten gains as the
marshals rode into town all the criminals were
playing cards in the saloon except for roy dowdy
aka arkansas tom jones who was sick in bed in his
room of the ok hotel as george newcomb exited
the saloon the marshals opened fire prompting
all of the outlaws to abandon their poker game
and responding kind within seconds the tiny town
of ingles transformed into a war zone covered
in smoke with bullets flying in every direction
hearing the commotion outside arkansas tom jones
went to the window of his hotel room and opened
fire on the lawmen mortally wounding deputy
marshal tom houston the surprise attack allowed
some of the other outlaws to make their way to
the stable and retrieve their horses they charged
out of delivery with their guns blazing and killed
two more marshals lafayette shadley and dick speed
as well as an innocent bystander who got caught in
the crossfire with the lawmen on the defensive the
wild bunch was able to ride out of town with only
a few minor injuries to show for their troubles
there was still a little matter of arkansas
tom jones who was trapped inside his hotel
room given that they had just lost three of their
own the marshals were in no mood to negotiate so
they gave jones two options surrender or they'd
throw dynamite in his room jones surrendered was
arrested and later convicted to 50 years in prison
although he was released after serving less than
20. strangely enough getting caught prolonged
his life substantially as he outlived all of
his compatriots by two to three decades however
during the 1920s jones started robbing banks again
and in 1924 he was finally killed in a gunfight
in joplin missouri as the last of the wild bunch
after making an escape from ingles the rest
of the gang decided to lay low for the rest
of the year but in 1894 they were back to their
old shenanigans and by shenanigans we of course
mean robbery violence and the occasional murder
a stagecoach in arkansas a train in oklahoma bank
in kansas little by little the wild bunch were
becoming the biggest terror in the west but it was
their little stunt in engles that made them public
enemies number one in the eyes of the marshals
undoubtedly there were more than a few lawmen
who would have loved to catch the gang members in
their crosshairs the officers doggedly pursued the
wild bunch from state to state led by a famed tree
of marshals named bill tillman heck thomas and
chris madsen who were collectively known as three
guardsmen and who knows maybe one day we'll cover
them on biographics as well anyway having the law
constantly on their trail didn't seem to deter
the wild bunches the gang committed one brazen
act after another including a daring raid on
southwest city missouri which saw the wild
bunch successfully ride out of town following a
bank robbery despite the fact that marshalls and
townspeople fired at them from both sides of the
street as the gang was making its getaway there
was another successful score that left the gang
unscathed and almost four thousand dollars richer
it really seemed like the wild bunch had
more than a few rabbits feed tucked away
somewhere in their saddles the way they kept
avoiding any serious injuries but their luck
was about to run out and it started with none
other than bill dalton on june 8 1894 dalton was
lying low at his home in ardmore oklahoma when
a posse of armed lorman surrounded the house
if bill would have exited his home hands held high
in the air he might have survived but that's not
how things played out instead he jumped out the
window gun in hand and started running towards
the posse it was one final act of defiance from
a man who decided to go out on his own terms
as you might imagine he was immediately ripped to
shreds by the hell of gunfire the final dalton had
been dealt with marking an end to one of the
most feared names to come out of the old west
his wife who stuck by his side and raised the
kids while he was out with the rest of the wild
bunch identified his body and had it shipped to
california to be buried for the rest of the gang
even with dalton's death it was business as usual
since it was unlikely that any of them expected
to make it to old age anyway even so the rest of
the year was pretty quiet with no other notable
events occurring in 1894. 1895 however was a
completely different story as all the other
wild bunch members started getting picked off
one by one first off tulsa jack blake on april
3 1895 five members of the gang had just robbed
another train near rock island oklahoma and made
camp for the night in a basin along the simmering
river unbeknownst to him a posse of us marshall
sniffed out their train and approached their camp
in the dead of night the lawmen called for the
outlaws to surrender but of course this was never
going to happen another wild shootout erupted and
roughly 200 shots later the gunsmoke cleared blake
lay dead while the rest of the bandits managed to
make their escape just a month later the wild
bunch lost two of its founding members george
bittercreek newcomb and charlie pierce on may the
second the two of them traveled to the dunn ranch
in payne county oklahoma nukem wanted to visit his
lover a woman named rose dunn pretty famous in her
own right but better known as rose of cimarron
the gang were also on friendly terms with their
brothers who they knew from engle so newcomen
peers felt pretty safe as they approached the
ranch what they didn't know is that the dunn
brothers preferred money over friendship and
they intended to collect on the large bounties
placed on all members of the wild bunch so then
newcomb and pierce showing up at their home was
like a turkey basting and stuffing itself and then
jumping into the oven on its own volition
the temptation was just too great so as the
two unsuspecting outlaws got off their horses
they were ambushed and gunned down and the dunn
brothers became several thousand dollars richer
four months later another member of the gang
named little bill raidler was shot and injured
by one of the three guardsmen and taken in alive
he was sent to jail for 10 years but released
in 1903 due to health issues and he died a year
later therefore bradley became the only member
of the wild bunch not to be killed directly in
a gunfight even though his death came as a result
of the injuries that he sustained in his shootout
with the marshals by 1896 half of the gang was
gone and the other half had split up hoping to
evade the authorities as long as possible george
redbuck weightman was killed in another gunfight
with the marshals on march the 4th 1896 while
dynamite dick clifton and little dick west were
gunned down in 1897 and 1898 respectively we're
left with just one man bill doolin the leader
of the wild bunch in june 1896 guardsman
bill tillman captured him without incident
at eureka springs arkansas and sent him to federal
prison in guthrie oklahoma to await trial as it
happened clifton was also in prison there so the
two of them and a dozen other inmates executed a
prison break on july the 5th doolin ran away to
his father-in-law's farm in lawson oklahoma to
be with his wife and son perhaps he realized that
it was the end of the road for him so he wanted
one more chance to see his family unsurprisingly
marshall soon tracked him down to the homestead on
august 25 1896 they trapped doolin in an ambush
like dalton he could have surrendered but he
preferred to go out shooting so doolin raised
his gun and aimed it at the marshals but didn't
get a chance to pull the trigger before one of
the deputies emptied a double-barreled shotgun
straight into his chest and then there were
none eleven violent deaths for eleven violent
men meant the end of the most ruthless gang
that the old west had ever seen the gang known
as the wild bunch i hope you found today's
video interesting if you did please do hit
that like button below don't forget to
subscribe and thank you for watching